there are many creatures in Greek
mythology but few are as majestic and
more known as Pegasus Pegasus is
traditionally depicted as a pure white
horse
sometimes with golden wings capable of
flight the winged steed was the
offspring of Poseidon the god of the sea
and the Gorgon Medusa Medusa was
pregnant with Pegasus but she could not
give birth because of the curse placed
on her by Athena when she was eventually
slain Pegasus was born from the wound of
her severed neck there are some variant
accounts as to what Pegasus did after
birth some claim that shortly after
being born Pegasus flew to Mount Olympus
where he would live in Zeus's palace
Zeus gave Pegasus the task in carrying
the gods thunder and lightning and it
was during this time on Mount Olympus
that Athena tamed Pegasus
so that mortals could ride the steed
there are other stories that would
suggest that Pegasus spent some time on
earth before flying to Mount Olympus
whilst on earth Pegasus served and aided
to the two heroes Bella laughs run and
Perseus there were many who tried to
tame Pegasus but none was successful
until the hero Bellerophon was given a
golden bridle by the goddess Athena upon
seeing the golden bridle Pegasus came
willingly to aid Bell in the front in
his battle against the Chimera of Lycia
now considered a hero Bell Olaf run
decided that he would take his rightful
place amongst the gods of Mount Olympus
Zeus was aware of Bela Franz plan to
ride Pegasus to Mount Olympus and
intervened by sending a gadfly to sting
Pegasus dismount in Balala from in some
versions of the story bella la fronte
died after his fall and in others he
survived but he was cursed to roam the
earth and never see Mount Olympus
Pegasus however continued the journey to
Mount Olympus and as mentioned before
would make Zeus his palace its new home
the hero Perseus also rode Pegasus when
rescuing princess Andromeda who he would
later marry the princess Andromeda and
Pegasus developed a deep bond and you
can see this connection in their
constellations which can be found
side-by-side there are some mentions in
later mythology of Pegasus and the four
muses in these depictions Pegasus lived
on Mount Helicon with the muses Pegasus
was seen as a great source of
inspiration to the muses and one day the
muses took part in a singing contest
their song was so impressive that it
caused the mountain that they stood on
to swell up in admiration Pegasus was
ordered by Poseidon to land upon Mount
Helicon and relieve the mountain
swelling as commanded Pegasus touched
down and began galloping and stamping
down against the ground
eventually the stallions hard work paid
off and the spring named Hippocrene was
created and the mountain Suellen began
to reduce it is believed that many of
the sacred Springs in Greece were
created when Pegasus touched down Zeus
decided that he would immortalize
Pegasus by placing the winged steed
amongst the Stars
Pegasus became a constellation and can
be seen today in both the northern and
southern hemispheres in autumn and
spring over the years Pegasus has been
associated of creativity and inspiration
it is undoubtedly one of the most iconic
creatures in Greek mythology I'd love to
hear from you guys is Pegasus one of
your favorite creatures in Greek
mythology or like me do you prefer
something along the lines of the Gryphon
let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology in
fiction explained